[Musique]
le roi arthur revient dix ans qu'on a
plus vu son pif il es cannet fils
pendragon le 7 12 j'étais allé chez
nations à cause de la diète évidemment
qu'il est pas mort ça fait dix ans que
je vous dis gros salsifis bon dieu par
tous les saints
commencez pas je suis absolument pas
roya pas besoin de se lever camelot
premier volet qu'est ce que vous
entendez exactement pas vous êtes de
retour dès fois que vous re deux miroirs
voilà maintenant si vous le sentez pas
où ils sont et pas
au cinéma le 21 juillet
le roi arthur revient
si on fait des passages je sais pas ce
que vous faites il y aurait moyen de
réduire la voilure sur la connaît il
veut dire ça dans le bon sens du terme
camelot premier volet vous faites deux
cent pas sur le chemin et vous monter la
garde au cas où quelqu'un approche
approche son chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous monter la garde et si la
personne qui approche je prends revient
non vous monter la garde
au cinéma le 21 juillet
puis le roi arthur vient vous êtes de
retour et ça c'est vraiment une bonne
nouvelle pour nous tous un bien sûr mais
surtout pour le peuple breton pierre a
commencé sérieusement tire la langue
c'est à dire c'est métaphorique petit il
tire pas littéralement tous la langue
sont au bout du rouleau bras
c'est par amitié par pas littéralement
un gros rouleau avec des jambes camelot
premier volet voilà maintenant si vous
ne sentez pas ou ne sentais pas au
cinéma le 21 juillet
arthur pendragon
un gars pas bien long non convaincu me
disant qu'on a plus vu son pif il et
cannelle fils pendragon sait tous
évidemment qu'il est pas mort ça fait
dix ans que nous vivons ça suffit mon
dieu
non non non commencez par je suis
absolument pas royer pas besoin de celui
à venir la retrouver le jeu vous fait
tous prendre le palais partie bravo
alors c'est très constructif
la résistance ça vous dit quelque chose
aller au but
lisez ça pouvait être intéressant
d'organiser une rencontre avec les
représentants de la résistance vous
entendez quelque chose et active avec
une boîte tonding nba va vous entendu
quelque chose pour faire quelque chose
de complètement informée c'est pas
possible d'être largué voilà
comment ça se passe cette petite
résistance
bon vous faites deux cent pas sur le
chemin et vous monter la garde au cas où
quelqu'un approche approche sur le
chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous monter la garde et s'il ya
personne qui approche je prends revient
non vous monter la garde
il y aurait moyen de réduire la voilure
sur l'inconnu
deux fils pendragon est de retour en bas
qui viennent
il faut tuer arthur vous ne savez pas
faire ça entraîner les troupes
les sciers jeu
il faisait pas impensable
bah oui mais j'en prenais pas des
débiles aussi j'entraînais des débiles
mais pas des débiles comme ça
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
par vous êtes de retour dès fois que
vous redevenir roi quoi oui oui bah si
c'est vrai que ça fait envie quoi voilà
maintenant si vous le sentez pas vous le
sentez pas